nombre de cas positifs repart à la
hausse plus de 22 mille par jour + 26%
sur une semaine ce qui explique les
spécialistes c'est qu'il y a eu
relâchement des mesures barrières mais
surtout arriver de nouveau sous variant
de mikron qu'ils sont plus transmissible
400 admission qu vite par jour environ
en baisse de presque 10% sur une semaine
pour l'instant la haute autorité de
santé recommande d'anticiper pour
l'automne une campagne de rappel
vaccinal pour les personnes les plus à
risque de formes graves mais selon
l'évolution les experts n'excluent pas
une vaccination plus large peut-être
avec un nouveau vaccin mieux adapté aux
variants on va en parler bien sûr de de
ça gilles verdez moi je dis que il faut
absolument remettre tout de suite le
masque dans les
questions soient plus de cas en ile de
france sur les trois dernières semaines
ça flambe en plus c'est au micron 5 4 et
5 on dit qu'il est totalement insensible
à l'immunité collective
donc on va tous être contaminés on ne
fait rien pour moi c'est du délire et
c'est pour ça aussi je disais qu'il
fallait annuler la fête de la musique je
sais que ces minoritaires mais ça a été
des clusters on va s'apercevoir que le
l'épidémie flambée on ne fait rien moi
je suis sidéré a déjà gilles raconte
n'importe quoi le mhave aussi alors je
paie que gilles c'est le chroniqueur
préféré de la production dit il j'adore
gilles mais sur ce sujet c'est juste pas
possible au portugal ils ont eu déjà eu
la vague du bea 5 et la création
et voilà et vous voyez comme vous voyez
sur le schéma elle est déjà retombée
nous on a eu une vague pendant les
belles et la préparation des
présidentielles pendant la campagne on
n'a pas eu de mesure puisqu'il a élevé
enlever le mas qu'ils avaient enlevé
toutes les mesures pour des raisons
électoralistes et la vague est monté
légèrement elle est redescendue et là au
portugal c'est ce qui se passe il faut
arrêter il faut réintégrer les soignants
suspendu il faut arrêter la psychose il
faut que les personnes à risque se
protège si elle le souhaite il faut
respecter le choix libre et éclairé de
chacun en leur donnant une information
complète et respectée selon l'individu
et l'historique médical et c'est tout
est art le connaissons le but à 5 là
ça c'est les anglais c'est que
c'est les anglais ça s'est passé sous
l'eau c'est sûr c'est le tunnel sous la
manche ou encore les anglais à cela en
ce pluvieux peu plus de cheveux peut
plus oui moi je pense que les médias
devraient arrêter de parler du co lead
en fait ils jouent avec la peur des gens
par déclic et de l'audience mais quand
on lit tous les articles c'est pareil
ils disent oui remontée des cas mais peu
ou pas de forme grave donc à quoi ça
sert de parler du coup vite puisque de
toute façon a priori on les radis cra
jamais à rien à part affaire continue à
faire peur aux gens donc les médias ont
vraiment un rôle là dedans parce qu'ils
alimentent un climat anxiogène qui est
insupportable on n'en peut plus du colis
de ces bons un stop alors n'est que vous
nous avez parlé du coc vide 1-2 de
christophe et un instant donc quand vous
entendez ça vous dit cc il faut vous
faites attention quand même moi je suis
pas avec la wii a vraiment un ouais
ouais c'est votre voilà vous dit non je
ne suis pas contre les gens qui font
bien sûr mais vous c'est votre choix
perso je vais faire pour vivre
normalement pendant à bata sont à qui
m'arrive est que sauf du confinement je
les ai vécus dans ma maison pas paris
quand les mots de christophe ça vous a
pas du tout fait réfléchir au nom parce
que christophe jeudi le plus grave
c'était ses poumons et son l'emphysème
covin bien sûr mais de toute façon voyez
bien que tous les vaccins
malheureusement je sais que les gens qui
vont entendre dont des amis à moi
proches ils vont hurler mais il voyait
bien que l'on peut être un vaccin 4,5
sich um ce choc quand même envie que sa
fille vient de l'attraper il à la
ramasse il s'est fait vacciner moi j'ai
peur parce que je ne sais pas fiable en
vaccins en fin de compte mais moi je
suis pas chercheuse nature je ne sais
pas je ne peux donc vous voyez on avait
trouvé quelque chose ça me rend juste
misons pas protéger les îles ont papoté
les gens protéger les gens avant c'est
ça qui est grave même s'il avait été
vacciné serait peut être pas mort
peut-être voilà on n'en sait rien
n'annonçait pas vacciner il est mort oui
il ya des
noms mais je vous dit le professeur m'a
dit qu'il avait une grippe que j'ai dit
bon il a fait peut-être des conneries
n'a fait il m'avait dit qu'il ferait pas
taratata il l'a fait banque fera et le
professeur m'a dit même s'il avait eu
une grippe ou la l'oxygène ne prenait
pas d'accord donc voyez vous le dimanche
depuis la première semaine y avait
tellement de chance vous avez beaucoup
de chance que ça je me suis ni va s'en
sortir mais laïque dimanche et le prof
qui m'a créé mais on va arrêter
traitement j'ai compris
fini ce que le colis dont un joli but
daniel moi je voudrais juste pousser un
petit coup de gueule c'est à dire que là
c'est vraiment alors genre avec tous les
gens qui ne veulent plus lente selon
certains quotidiens
soit 10,2 veulent pas se faire vacciner
moi je voudrais faire vacciner ma mère
c'est bon choix j'ai envie de la
protéger
je viens d'apprendre que le centre
médical de fontenay rose ma ville non
ils n'ont pas aujourd'hui alors qu'il
est deux ados d'alexis mal c'est à dire
celle au bon moment pour vacciner parce
que sa maman était pour les gens très
fragile je je je ne force personne du
tout à se faire vacciner eh bien ça fait
2 ans il n'ya pas d'anticipation il n'y
a pas de doses de vaccin pour l'instant
et ça je commence à en avoir marre parce
qu'on pouvait dire qu'on savait pas il
ya deux ans maintenant c'est c'est le
bon moment je fais tout ce que je peux
je veux faire tout bien et ben voila je
vais me retrouver encore dans une galère
parce qu'elle ne peut pas aller dans une
pharmacie que ça va être encore le
parcours du combattant que je suis
furieuse voilà ce que fait le film que
je n'en pense savoir à combien de doses
ta maman ben c'est que ça va être sa
quatrième normalement ça et c'est
manquer plus ou moins elle est quand
même ça les protégés fo va et non car
je m'étais où on doit plus parler du coc
vite c'est bien celui là parce que si on
recommence à remettre des restrictions
les gens vont définitivement pété un
plomb durant je pense que avec les
variants qui malaria c'est de plus en
c'est de moins en moins grave donc s'il
faut arrêter d'avoir une grippette et
même s'ils ont tous tous les six mois
c'est pas grave mais il faut ré ouvrir
parce que les gens deviennent agressifs
ils en ont vraiment marre et on ne peut
plus ni du vaccin ni du masque et n'y
dépasse sanitaires